so this darker curve in blue is the
graph of R is equal to one minus cosine
of theta of course we're dealing in
polar coordinates here and what I'm
interested in is to see if we can figure
out the area enclosed by this curve and
I encourage you to pause the video and
try it on your own all right let's work
through it together so we've already
seen we've already given ourselves the
intuition for the formula that the area
enclosed by a polar graph is going to be
equal to one half the definite integral
from you should say are starting our
starting theta to our ending data from
alpha to beta of R of theta squared D
theta and so we essentially just or we
just have to apply this to this function
right over here so in this case the area
is going to be equal to one half the
definite integral now what's our alpha
and what's our beta what we're going
from theta is equal to zero radians and
we're essentially going all the way when
theta is equal to zero radians is one
minus one where right over here and then
we go all the way around to theta is
equal to two pi radians notice when
we're back at two pi cosine of two pi is
one one minus one is zero again so we
get back to that point so we're going
from theta is equal to zero radians to
theta is equal to two pi radians now
what's R of theta squared
I mean I'll color code this a little bit
R of theta squared well it's just going
to be one minus cosine of theta one
minus cosine theta squared and of course
we have our D theta we have our D theta
and now we just have to evaluate this
integral so once again at any point you
feel inspired try to evaluate this so
let's do this alright so what I would do
so this is going to be equal to one half
times the definite integral from 0 to
2pi and let me expand this out this is
going to be
one minus two cosine theta plus cosine
squared theta D theta D theta now I know
how to take the antiderivative one I
know how to take the antiderivative
negative cosine of theta but cosine
squared theta this is a little bit it's
not it doesn't jump out at you that you
can just do is use u substitution or
something like that but lucky for us we
have our trigonometric identities and so
we know we know that cosine squared of
theta is just the same thing as one half
times one plus cosine of two theta you
learn this in trigonometry class if you
didn't what you learned it just now and
so that's why that well this is one of
the more useful trigonometric identities
but if you're if you're finding any type
of antiderivative if we're integrating
anything and so let's do that
let's rewrite this right over here as
1/2 times 1 plus cosine of two theta and
let's see and maybe we could wait yeah
let's just let's just do it like that I
guess we could if we want what we'll do
we'll just do it like that so this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to 1/2 and then we are going to
1/2 now let's just start taking anti
derivatives 1/2 now the antiderivative
of 1 with respect to theta is just going
to be theta the antiderivative of
negative 2 cosine of theta well that's
just going to be negative 2 sine of
theta negative 2 sine theta
you take the derivative the derivative
of sine is cosine and the negative 2
just it'll just multiply it times the
derivative of sine of theta so it's
negative 2 cosine of theta and then
we're going to have let's see actually
let me distribute this this is the same
thing as 1/2 plus 1/2 cosine of 2 theta
so let's just assume well it's this way
so the antiderivative of 1/2 so the
antiderivative of 1/2 so I'm really
looking at that right over there it's
going to be 1/2 theta 1/2 theta
and then the antiderivative of 1/2
cosine of 2 theta
let's see sine the derivative of sine of
2 theta is 2 cosine of 2 theta so this
is going to so the antiderivative is 1
the antiderivative of cosine of 2 theta
and you can do u substitution if you
like but you might be able to do this in
your head the antiderivative of cosine
of 2 theta is going to be 1/2 sine of 2
theta and then you have this 1/2 right
over here so this is going to be let me
show you what I'm finding the
antiderivative of that right over there
of this and I guess this right over here
this is going to be plus 1/4 sine of 2
theta and I encourage you to define the
derivative here too if you if that last
part was a little bit confusing
derivative of sine of 2 theta is 2
cosine of 2 theta 2 over 1/4 is 1/2 you
get 2 1/2 cosine of 2 theta and we're
going to evaluate that at 2 pi at 2 pi
and at 0 so when you evaluate it well
one thing that might jump out at is when
you evaluate this at 0 the single whole
thing is everything every term here is
just going to be 0 so that simplifies
things nicely so we really just have to
take 1/2 of it evaluated at 2 pi so this
is going to be 1/2 times 2 pi 2 pi and
then sine of 2 pi is 0 so that's just
going to be 0 and then plus 1/2 times 2
pi so that's going to be plus pi and
then sine of 2 times 2 pi sine of 4 pi
that's still going to be 0 so this is
going to be 0 as well and we are almost
done so this is going to be 1/2 times 3
pi or 3 halves
3 halves pi is the area is the area of
this region